I want to start this segment by
apologizing to all of you for putting
this image in your head
but it is breaking news and I believe
this shows the depravity and the evil of
the people who are in opposition or I
should say our establishment uniparty
and what
from CNN
former Trump aide Cassidy Hutchinson
claims Rudy Giuliani groped her on day
of attack on Capital wow such a shocking
story to come out a day before her book
release is that right yeah it's a day or
two something I don't know the exact
timing but yep wow oh so she accused
Rudy Giuliani of groping her
that's and that that's coming out in her
book so congratulations PR Company hit
the nail now with the hammer you people
are evil I I I have a problem or I've
always had a problem with people falsely
caught using racism as an excuse for
everything and